the Senate staffer was discovered over
the weekend to have filmed himself
committing an extremely inappropriate
action in the Senate Judiciary hearing
room now this is a family show so I'm
not going to use any explicit language
but I do want to cover the story which
exposes a lot it exposes everything just
about but specifically it exposes the
flagrant degeneracy that has for some
time now rotted our leading public
institutions so instead of explicit
language I am going to use euphemisms
that were crowdsourced from Twitter to
describe this
action some are describing what was
filmed in the Senate hearing room as an
insurrecto others have suggested that
this staffer simply misread the sign on
the door and thought he was entering the
Senate rearing room still others have
called the display a clear-cut case of
rump derangement syndrome I for one take
a more charitable view because in their
defense these two men were simply acting
out what the US Senate does to the
American people every single day the
staffer is reportedly a Democrat of
course named Aiden Mai
shopsky according to writer and
political strategist Ryan guski the
staffer appeared in a campaign video
back in 2020 for Joe Biden
Biden posted the video to Twitter with
the comment quote from the bottom of my
heart thank
you one can almost hear the staffer
responding quote from the heart of my
bottom Mr President thank you too now
for his part the staffer is sort of
denying the
accusations but the denial fell flat
after he was promptly removed from the
Senate staff in the wake of the Scandal
even a cursory glance at screenshots
from the Stafford social media channels
shall we say lend credibility to the
allegations so the young Democrat took
to LinkedIn to explain himself quote
this has been a difficult time for me
the staffer wrote as I have been
attacked for who I love to pursue a
political agenda while some of my
actions in the past have shown poor
judgment I love my job and would never
disrespect my workplace any attempts to
characterize my actions otherwise are
fabricated and I will be exploring what
legal options are available to me in
these matters now it sounds crazy but as
a member of a legally protected class
there's a non-zero chance this guy walks
away or limps away perhaps with a payout
that is how identity politics works
today hence the reference to being quote
attacked for who I
love but the issue with this young man
is not who he loves but but rather How
He Loves contrary to popular bumper
stickers there are different kinds of
love as well as right and wrong ways to
love you love your wife and you love
your dog but you do not one hopes love
them in the same way you certainly can't
love a male Senate staffer in the way
that you love your wife it's not
physically possible and even if you
could it would still be wrong kind of
funny but extremely wrong and disgusting
to do it in a senate hearing room I'm
Michael nlls this is the Michael nlls
[Music]
show welcome back to the show The White
House has released a super weird
Christmas video with tap dancing that we
will get to I'm of two minds on the
video I will bring my pop culture
expertise to bear on on analyzing that I
also will point out that Christmas is
what five days away no a little more
than that guess you've got like seven
days great gift to give is Birch gold
right now text nolles to 9898 98
diversify your savings with physical
precious metals while stockpiling silver
in your home safe take advantage of
Birch gold group's most popular special
of the year now through December 22nd
for every $5,000 you spend with Birch
gold they will send you a 1 o Silver
Eagle Coin for free Tex NES kwes to 98
9898 to claim your eligibility now you
can purchase gold and silver and have it
shipped directly to your home or have
Birch Gold's precious metal Specialists
help you convert an existing Ira or 401K
into a tax sheltered Ira in gold for no
money out of pocket they will send you
free silver for every $5,000 you
purchase keep it for yourself or give
something with real value as a stocking
stuffer this year it's pretty good
stocking stuffer just checks the word
nolles to 998 9898 to claim your
eligibility with an A+ rating with the
Better Business Bureau thousands of
happy customers now is the best time to
buy gold from Birch gold text nolles
kwes to 98 9898 claim your eligibility
for free silver un qualifying purchases
before December 22nd that is nolles kwes
to 98
9898 a lot has happened since I've been
away some of you know I was in India I
went to India because I posted on
Twitter I said should I move to India
and become a professional sitar player I
will abide by the results of this poll
and you people sent me to India so I'm a
man of my word I took it very seriously
I flew from uh Nashville to Atlanta
Atlanta to Paris Paris to Dubai then I
got in a car in Dubai took a a taxi to
charia airport then flew from Char to
thuram and but then here's here's where
things got a little dicey I I forgot my
sitar you know you're packing it's
hectic oh did I remember my toothbrush
did I remember my sitar so I got there I
realized I didn't have my sitar I posted
another poll I said should I I can't get
my hands on a sitar should I go go back
and pick up my sitar before then
returning to India to to pursue my dream
of becoming a professional satar player
and you voted yes so then I flew back uh
from anuram to Dubai Dubai to Amsterdam
Amsterdam to New York gfk took a cab to
New York LaGuardia then took a flight
back to uh Nashville Airport last night
um the trip was not a total loss because
coincidentally a very close friend of
mine just coincidentally happened to be
getting married in India during that
trip so what not a total loss but good
to be back so much has happened since I
was gone actually so much has happened
even since I wrote this show last night
which is that uh apparently someone
rammed into President Biden's motorcade
which means that the number of Democrats
who are getting rear ended these days is
much higher than one would have expected
and then there was even more important
news Tim P came out with a cover of
together again the famed hit by Smoky
Mike and the god king and the song Hit
number one on the iTunes chart which is
where you should go right now to
download it now there's a whole
backstory to Smoky Mike and the god king
which can hear in Tim's teaser for the
song the year is 1967 and something
incredible happens to music Smoky Mike
and the god king unveiled their hit song
together again the song was massive
charting in both 1967 and 1968 and spent
87 weeks at number
one needless to say America was hooked
and a legacy was born a legacy that
continues to this
day what inspired you to bring a song of
this magnitude into the world world I
think it's no secret that our band was
effectively done after Ian was caught
mercilessly beating that child but I was
I was hoping there was some way we could
turn things around working with my
mentor Phil leonti I asked him is there
is there is there something we can do
that's not been done that'll be big and
and he pointed out with all these greats
like the Beatles with Zeppelin you know
and Smoky Mike and the god king there
are a lot of opportunities for modern
versions that have not been done
properly now a lot of people have
covered Zeppelin of course but no one's
done a good modern version of together
again and he was right and I think
that's when we realized if we get this
we get this right it could be
huge could be huge now the backstory to
that backstory is a couple years ago
Jeremy and I played our song to a
soldout crowd at the
[Music]
Ryman growing stronger with you I'm
growing stronger with you this time the
deepest low the lowest high the blackest
days The Bluest
night in no storm we cannot weather my
friend
only
again so you got the backstory and the
backstory of the backstory but there's
actually a backstory to the backstory of
the backstory and that backstory is what
is politically relevant the story is
that Jeremy and I wanted to cover Happy
Together by The Turtles for that show we
thought it would be funny but since it
was being videotaped we needed to secure
the rights to the song which is usually
just a perfunctory request immediately
granted for a minor fee unless it's
conservatives who are the ones who want
to cover the music in which case the
request gets shut down we were shocked
we talked to friends in the music
industry one extremely successful
songwriter in particular was shocked he
said he'd never heard of such a request
being rejected so we called the company
that holds the rights and we tried to
clear it up they said no we offered more
money they said no we offered even more
money no finally Jeremy who will pay any
price for a joke offered them
$50,000 150 Grand just for the
performance rights one time to this old
song and we were told that there is no
amount of money we could offer that
would get us the rights so we had no
other choice but to write a song
ourselves which is how the original
together again was born which is how Tim
pool's cover of together again was born
which is an excellent cover by the
[Music]
way with
you I've been so long it's time going
stronger with
you
keep his low the lowest size blackest
days and blest night ain't no storm we
can ra my friend if we just come
together
[Music]
again great song worth buying in its own
right but especially worth buying when
you remember that you can stick it to
lib music Executives who hate us for the
low price of only 67 or whatever the I
don't know what a song costs to download
on iTunes but for that low price you can
get it so please if you love great music
if you love owning the libs if you are
not that attached to the change in your
pocket please head on over to iTunes or
Amazon music to download Together Again
by Tim P by Michael nolles and Jeremy
boring Smoky Mike and the god king
today speaking of owning the
libs there's a an American hero who
deserves some credit even though the
stories a few days old at this point
Michael Cassidy 35-year-old former Navy
pilot who showed up to the Iowa state
capital while I was gone one of the last
stories we covered on the show before I
flew to India was the story of the
satanic statue being erected by the
satanic temple in the Iowa state capital
and the way that this was permitted to
happen is because of a gross misreading
of the First Amendment and The
Establishment Clause of the First
Amendment and the notion of religious
freedom in the American political
tradition because of a gross liberal
leftist atheist BS misreading of that
there is now a statue of sorry there was
a statue of baffet a a devil a demon up
in the Iowa state capital until this guy
Michael Cassidy 35-year-old former Navy
pilot went in knocked it over and
beheaded the statue just would like to
take a brief
pause to Applause to applaud rather uh
Mr
Cassidy great work American hero he's
now charged with fourth deegree criminal
mischief I do not
Advocate uh disturbing the public order
I do not Advocate destroying property
private or public property I but you
know it really is difficult for me to
take seriously the left-wing objections
to knocking down statues when the left
has spent the last 5 10 I don't know 30
years but especially in in the last 5 to
10 years destroying beautiful statues of
important American Heroes beheading
statues of Christopher Columbus tearing
down statues of Thomas Jefferson
attacking statues of Frederick Douglas
okay and US
Grant after they've been doing that and
we were told this is wonderful this is
beautiful this is Liberation this is for
equality and fairness then a a Navy
pilot goes in and tears down a statue of
the actual devil in the Iowa state
capital at Christmas time time and we're
told oh it's it's a terrible crime throw
him in jail throw away the key what did
Mr Cassidy say about this he said the
world may tell Christians to
submissively accept the legitimization
of Satan but none of the founders would
have considered government sanction of
satanic altars inside capital buildings
is protected by the First Amendment
totally true if you want to learn more
about that fact that is misunderstood
today you can go get speechless
controlling words controlling Minds my
book on this very topic thank you very
much uh Mr Cassy goes on anti-christian
values have steadily been mainstreamed
more and more in recent decades and
Christians have largely acted like the
proverbial frog in the Boiling Pot of
water totally true 100% correct thank
you Mr Cassidy for accurately and
concisely articulating the the true
meaning of the First Amendment The
Establishment Clause and religious
freedom I'm sorry to say that the
Republican Iowa governor Kim Reynolds
had a completely wrong response to this
she said like many Iowans I find oh this
is just the squishiest oh man this is
just like the perfect squish take on
sorry I'm going to get through it
without without articulating my disgust
the entire time here's what she said
like many Ians I find the satanic
temples display in the capital
absolutely objectionable in a free
Society the best response to
objectionable speech is more speech and
I would encourage all those of Faith to
join me today in praying over the
capital and recognizing the nativity
scene that will be on display the true
reason for the season yeah okay this is
like a an excrement sandwich of an
answer because the first part is pretty
good yes I find the satanic display
objectionable good I'm glad you're not a
Satanist Governor Reynolds great I find
it totally objectionable that's the
first part the bottom part the bottom
bun is we should all be praying we
should be recognizing the Nativity
seeing the crash in the capital it's
Christmas season yeah absolutely that's
true but then there's that excrement
right in the middle of her answer which
is it's a free Society so we need to the
the best best thing we can do is
encourage the satanists to have their
stupid display up and then we'll have
our display and then we'll have the
endless displays and that's a free
Society there is
no there is no satanic alter guarantee
in the religious freedom tradition of
the United States there is no satanic
altar sanction for listed in the First
Amendment or The Establishment Clause
total weak sauce from governor pathetic
actually I don't I hate to be so harsh
on a fellow Republican but it's a
pathetic
answer yes we should be offended by the
satanic display yes we should pray and
recognize the nativity scene we we in no
way have to hand it to the satanists
ever under any circumstances okay I'm
not saying that I support tearing down
statues and beheading them and if it's
private or public property but what Mr
Cassidy did here is certainly one of the
more Justified viable acts of civil
disobedience in recent years we've heard
a lot about the importance of Civil
Disobedience when it's BLM going around
murdering people for8 months going
around burning down buildings and and
looting sneaker stores that's a
wonderful display of Civil Disobedience
but when it's someone attacking an
actual satanic Idol on government
grounds oh no no now you're attacking
the First Amendment give me a freaking
break if Governor reynolds's response is
the conservative response well actually
in a in a society we should encourage
the satanists yes and then we'll have
our speech and they'll have their speech
and we'll all just have we we'll just
increasing the number of baet displays
and and conversely Christian displays
until until no one can walk around the
capital because of all the little devil
statues standing around if that's the
conservative response who needs
conservatives what are conservatives
good for absolutely
nothing religious freedom there is no
religious freedom argument that
justifies these satanic temples display
here in large part because the satanic
temple admits that it's not a religious
organization the satanic satanic temple
openly explicitly says that it is a
mockery of religion they don't actually
even worship the devil so they think
they do but they just don't realize it
they they they're worshiping the devil
ironically which it is not possible to
do because if you ironically worship the
devil you are earnestly worshiping the
devil but anyway they think that it's
all just a big joke they're just a bunch
of edgy Reddit tier atheists so they
can't even claim that this is their
sincerely held religious belief they're
admitting that it's not there goes that
very basic religious freedom argument
but also religion is not just some
totally subjective term that we can
Define into meaning whatever we want it
to mean I know that the left has has
succeeded in recent years in convincing
people even conservatives often that
that words can just mean whatever we
want them to mean but religion has a
meaning religion is a habit of virtue
that inclines the will to give God what
he deserves that's religion okay
so worshiping Satan or not recognizing
God even for that
matter is not and has never seriously
been considered a matter of religious
freedom none of our founding fathers
would have said that was a matter of
religious freedom John lock the father
of liberalism the man who promoted
religious freedom he certainly wouldn't
have agreed with that he explicitly
opposed that view actually it's just
ridiculous but if this is the way we
talk about religious freedom now then I
think we need a better term just to make
it clear for people and the better
term ironically is an is an older term
and that's Toleration conservatives we
kind of make fun of the notion of
Tolerance say all these liberals they
just want tolerance all the you're going
to have museums to tolerance and all
this but Toleration is a good
thing I'm I'm very Pro
Toleration there's a big debate going on
now between Notions of America that that
involve Christian nationalism versus I
don't know I guess you'd call it just
total libertinism or
libertarianism uh they say the Christian
nationalists they're terrible they want
a theocracy they no not exactly I mean
all all governments have religious views
that's been true for all of history
everywhere in the world even today we
pretend to be secular and atheist but we
have religious views those religious
views are articulated in the Dei
initiatives diversity equity and
inclusion they're they're expressed in
the ESG initiatives and the the climate
religion that has taken over the the
world the of of course there are
religious views because all politics
ultimately comes down to theology all
all human conflict ultimately is
theological so what would it mean if if
we if we don't want to be a liberal
leftist Satan worshiping country and we
want to go back to being a Christian
country which is what we were founded to
be and what we always have have been
until very very recently then what does
that look like does that mean we're
going to be a rigid cruel theocracy that
is that is bad for Jews and Muslims and
agnostics even and atheists even and no
it doesn't actually means that we're
going to go back to being what we were
when we were a normal country which is
obviously Christian publicly Christian
uh founded to be a model of Christian
charity in a shiny city on a hill by
people who call themselves
pilgrims but we're going to have a a
wide degree of tolerance for religious
minorities and people who disagree and
that's a good thing but tolerance
doesn't mean that you need to put these
things on equal footings you might even
tolerate these redditer edgy atheist
so-called satanists to some degree you
might tolerate them having their stupid
rituals and practices in private to to
some
degree but we what it does not mean is
that we're going to put these things on
equal footing America Amica is not a
Muslim country I like Muslims I just
spent a lot of time with Muslims while I
was traveling over to India I like
Hindus spent a lot of time with Hindus I
like Jews I grew up in New York all
virtually all of my friends were Jewish
I I like even the red edgy
atheists of whom I was one for a long
period of my life I like all of these
people and their views can be given a a
a wide degree of
Tolerance but let's not pretend that
America is a Muslim country it's not it
never has been let's not pretend that
America is an atheist country it is not
it never has been and let's sure as hell
not pretend that America is a Satanist
country a satanic country which it at
least was not founded to be but which it
will be if we start exalting statues of
baffet in our state capitals have I made
my point clear I hope so now when you
want to protect yourself from our
increasingly satanic political order uh
you're going to want to check out
expressvpn
right now go to expressvpn.com Christmas
is a time of Joy gratitude and
reflection in the midst of these
festivities consider taking a moment to
reflect on the digital footprint that
accompanies you through the season think
about all the information on your phone
your search history your location the
websites you shop at and more companies
can legally gather this information and
sell it to advertisers for massive
profit that is why you need to do what I
do and trust your online security to
expressvpn expressvpn is an app on your
phone and computer that encrypts all of
your online traffic so that all your
online activity remains private if you
think that incognito mode is going to
stop people from tracking your online
activity think again read the fine print
that appears when you start browsing in
incognito mode says that your activity
might still be visible to your employer
your school or your internet service
provider with that expressvpn every site
you visit could be logged by the Admin
of that Network I love expressvpn
because I'm a lite and it's super easy
to use even I can use it the app has one
button once you turn it on you're
protected from prying eyes dailywire is
partnered with expressvpn to get you a
special Christmas offer go to
expressvpn.com right now get three extra
months for free
expressvpn.com expressvpn.com to learn
more Christmas season is upon us we call
it Advent this can only mean one thing
great discounts on dailywire plus right
now annual subscriptions are 30 30% off
that is one whole year of unlimited
access to adree uncensored exclusive
content from your favorite daily wire
hosts for 30% off join now to get access
to groundbreaking entertainment like our
new movie lady Ballers a recently
released docu series from Candace Owens
convicting a murderer as well as the
entire library of Jordan Peterson and
more if you have children you'll be
happy to hear that your dailywire plus
annual subscription comes with access to
dailywire kids' app vent key at no extra
charge vent key is also where you will
be able to watch Snow White and the evil
queen in 2024 and you don't want to miss
what we have coming in Daily wire Plus's
2024 season which is Mr burum the
animated comedy series featuring Adam
Corolla Roseanne Bar Megan Kelly Bret
Cooper and more we also have the highly
anticipated release of the pen Dragon
Cycle Plus so much more this Christmas
get yourself a daily wire plus annual
membership for 30% off this Christmas
give the gift of a daily wire plus
annual membership for 30% off at
dailywire.com subscribe and join
today speaking of religion and
government Democrat mayor Michelle who
has just invited some members of the
Boston government to a Christmas party
she's only invited some of them because
the Christmas party is for non-white
people so white people are not allowed
to go the only reason the white people
found out about this is because city
council relations director Denise dos
Santos accidentally sent an email to All
City Council Members inviting them to
the electeds of color holiday party
right off the bat you know it's it's a
bad it's a bad thing holiday part what's
the holiday what holiday are we
celebrating is it Quanza that's not a
real holiday virtually no one celebrates
Quanza it was a contrivance of a a woman
beating torturing socialist lunatic
named uh molana kenga his real name is
Ron Everett but during the Black Power
movement he renamed himself Milana kenga
and then he imprisoned women and put
soldering irons on them and hit them on
the with toasters and electrocuted them
and did all sorts of terrible things
anyway he invented Quanza as a socialist
holiday and virtually no one celebrates
it so it's not Quanza is it Hanukkah
Hanukkah is a minor Jewish holiday it
has been elevated in America to to be a
bigger holiday than it traditionally had
been in Judaism but only to make it the
kind of Jewish version of Christmas but
it's just not Jews have many more
significant holidays at different times
of the year H Quanza is or Hanukkah
rather is not not that big a deal it's
it's Christmas it's the holiday but the
libs can't say Christmas because they
hate Christianity and and True Religion
so they and and tradition and you know
apple pie and hot dogs and and anything
American at all that traditionally our
civilization likes so it's the electeds
of color holiday party and here's the
email on behalf of Mayor Michelle woo I
cordially invite you to the electeds of
color holiday party on Wednesday
December 13th at 5:30 p.m. at the
Parkman house 33 Beacon
Street some white people receive this
they say hold on wait what the electeds
of color do I and she then she follows
up she goes hey I wanted to apologize
for my previous email regarding the
holiday party for tomorrow oh notice she
doesn't call it the electeds of color
holiday party oh yikes the whites found
out about the the uh electeds of color
party okay no it's the holiday party for
tomorrow I did send that to everyone by
accident I apologize if my email may
have offended or came across as so now
this email is
almost not in coherent English well it's
not in coherent English it's almost
impossible to interpret you can tell
this person was flustered uh yikes uh
sorry if this may have offended or came
across as so as what huh as offensive or
I don't know sorry for any confusion
this may have
caused then at this point what should
happen is Mayor woo should come out and
fire this person and mayor woo should
come out and say this holiday party
holiday party is completely unacceptable
and we're not going to exclude whites
from government functions and we're not
going to legally discriminate against
white people anymore than we already do
which is to a pretty significant degree
no what did mayor woo do she defended
it she said Hey Now white people get to
go to plenty of parties this one though
no whites allowed this this government
party no whites are
allowed yeah sorry you shouldn't have
gotten the email hope you weren't
offended it's that classic you know you
don't apologize for for what you did
that was wrong you apologize for someone
else feeling offended I'm sorry if you
felt offended no the issue isn't the
email the issue isn't the feeling of
offense the issue is the party and it's
the party not because someone wants to
go to another government or work
function Christmas party a lot of people
don't want to do that at all it's it's
because the party is a symbol of
anti-white hatred which is the most
widespread and Powerful form of racism
in the entire country that's the issue
so much so that the Supreme Court
finally had to address the issue and
this year knocked down so-called
affirmative action in one narrow case
that would be in the case of Harvard
discriminating against white and Asian
students and the only reason it worked
is because that they could highlight the
the discrimination against Asians had it
only been a matter of discriminating
against white people the case would have
gone nowhere it is perfectly politically
acceptable it is politically encouraged
to insult white people and to legally
discriminate against them that's it's
encouraged the the leftist social
Engineers the the racial grievance
mongers they screwed up in affirmative
action by also discriminating against
Asians which gave those of us who don't
want cast systems of racial
discrimination uh the opportunity to go
in and say hold on now listen those
nasty terrible evil white people that's
obviously totally fine to discriminate
against them they're the devil the worst
people that ever lived but what about
the Asians and then finally that was
enough to get the Supreme Court to to
change it but but it it remains a major
issue and so here you you see a Democrat
mayor of a city getting caught in in a
really just ugly form of racial
discrimination and race hatred clearly
and what does she do she doubles down
doubles down not going anywhere anytime
soon folks but it's not a good look now
when you want to look good you got to
check out Jus cell right now go to
genucell.com there is a lot to be
stressed about during the Christmas
season well stress and lack of sleep can
easily cause those pesky under eye bags
good news is you never have to worry
about that when you have genous cell
skincare from now until Christmas Jus
cell's most popular package has a
special discount just for our listeners
at Jus cell.com treat yourself and your
loved ones to the absolute best skincare
in the world those troubling forehead
wrinkles Fine Lines skin redness and
even a sagging jaw line will disappear
right before your eyes with genus cell's
most popular collection genus cell
promises immediate effects you will see
results in less than 12 hours guaranteed
or your money back jell made Christmas
come early this year they sent down a
ton of products for the entire office
everyone Raves about their under eye
cream it works wonders plus included in
every most popular package is your free
hyaluronic acid serum for skin hydration
and restoration I love the company it's
absolutely fabulous the founder is a
Coptic Christian from Egypt left for the
American dream he uses the absolute top
ingredients that you can possibly use
and your first order is often discounted
because he knows that you are going to
stick around as a customer for a very
very long time like me jusl is simple
easily Satisfied by the very best of
everything go to Jus cell.com
canw to get this incredible Christmas
discount every order is instantly
upgraded to free express shipping Jus
cell.com
toay speaking of Democrats and
Christmas while I was gone this is a
little old but I have to cover I have to
get to this story just because I missed
a few shows last week while I was traing
through the subcontinent does not mean
that we're going to miss this the White
House released a really weird Christmas
video it's been totally polarizing
here's the
[Music]
[Applause]
video
[Music]
so if you're just listening to this now
there's not all that much to describe
it's you can hear the tap dancing going
on
lot of extremely colorful outfits and
personalities one one might confuse the
White House here for the Senate
Judiciary hearing
room and you know as one might expect
from the Democrats who put such a focus
on race and racial diversity you know
it's
uh you know to to totally out of Central
casting in that regard I kind of like
the video I kind of like it let me just
say kind of here because is it's not a
good
video but the reason it's not good is
not because of the concept of the video
I really like the concept of it I like
to focus on tap dancing tap dancing is a
really fun wholesome art form very
traditional American art
form the reason the video is not good is
because it it's not good tap
dancing it's not I don't mind the
colorful costumes are a little weird
they're they're a little on the
flamboyant Democrat side but whatever I
don't really care about that the extreme
ly on the nose diversity casting is I I
have no problem with people of all walks
of life tap dancing it's it's on the
nose the Democrats are always just so uh
conspicuous about this sort of thing but
again I don't that doesn't bother me in
the least some of some of my favorite
tap dancers are black guys you know
Gregory Hines or Sammy Davis Jr the
reason it's bad tap dancing gets to an
issue at the heart of leftist
politics which is that it's too
self-indulgent good really good tap
dancing is subtle it's understated it's
elegant you think of people like Fred a
stair you think of people like Jean
Kelly when they when they tap danceing
or Gregory hin or Sammy Davis Jr any of
any of these other tap dancers that I've
mentioned or not
mentioned their really beautiful tap
dancing is when you can hardly see the
moves and you just hear the Click Click
you know and it's it's just elegant it's
graceful their feet are moving you know
rapid Pace while their body is just so
elegant there's the sense of Stillness
and confidence and integrity that's
missing in the in the White House video
it's it looks like an elementary tap
class where every movement is just so
exaggerated and the biggest Smiles it
actually looks like the scene in Singing
in the Rain with Jean Kelly where it's a
flashback
to uh to Jean Kelly's bad days doing the
Vaudeville circuit you know fit as a
fiddle Ready For Love
and it's where all of the uh the
mannerisms are exaggerated and it's it's
a funny scene it's a delightful scene
but it's funny in that what he's doing
here is expressing a bad
dance that's what's going on here and
and it's just true of all of our modern
politics there's no sense anymore of
understatement of Elegance of humility
of of subtlety
that's gone now everything has to be so
exaggerated everyone has to be so uh
prideful and overthe toop and constantly
drawing attention to themselves in in
unattractive ways that's that's what I
don't like about it but I do like I do
like the tap dancing I just think about
today how many more exclamation points
you see in correspondence in the old
days in the days of Jean Kelly Freda
stair Gregory Hein Sam Davis Jr people
rarely used exclamation points in their
correspondence because an exclamation
point is like laughing at your own joke
it's an exclamation point is like this
White House tap dancing
video it
it's it's so unnecessary it's so
gratuitous today if you send a text
message or even a professional email
without 75 exclamation points people are
going to think you're a sociopath
they're going to think you're a stone
cold
killer it gets to that that underlying
in rot then the final problem with the
White House tap dancing video is I don't
I don't think they were actually
recording the Taps I think those Taps
were added in after the fact I'm not
positive but the Taps don't really seem
to line up with the foot movements prob
because the White House is just not
wired for tap dancing it's not like a
big tap stage in any case a good idea I
want to give the Biden White House I Joe
Biden was the one who posted this uh I
want to give them credit for having a
nice impulse but you you got to land the
execution too they did not speaking of
the bidens hunter Biden is speaking out
Hunter Biden has been asked to come and
testify before Congress before closed
door session not to make a big display
of everything Hunter showed up to DC he
showed up to the capital but he wouldn't
go to the close to recession he instead
made a big spectacle of himself in a
press conference outside the capital
proud of my legal career and business
career I'm proud of my time serving on a
dozen different Boards of
directors and I am proud of my efforts
to forge Global business
relationships for 6 years magga
Republicans including members of the
House committees who are in a closed
door session session right
now have imputed my
character invaded my privacy attacked my
wife my children my family and my
friends they ridiculed my struggle with
addiction they belittled my
recovery and they have tried to
dehumanize me all to embarrass and
damage my
father who has do devoted his entire
public life to
service for 6 years I have been the
target of the unrelenting Trump attack
machine shouting where's Hunter well
here's my answer I am here I am here
outside of the capital I am here I'm not
where you asked me to be I'm not here
where I would actually have to answer
for my crimes or my influence pedaling
or the fact that I was the bagman for my
corrupt father I'm here talking to the
liberal media here I am attacked his
wife and kids who's attacked his wife
and
kids have you heard a republican attack
Hunter Biden's wife and kids I know of
one person who has attacked Hunter
Biden's wife and kids that's Hunter
Biden which wife and kids are are we
talking about are we talking about the
wife that he left so that he could go
cheat with his
his dead brother's widow is that is that
the wife we're talking about which wife
which kid the kid that he callously
refused to acknowledge for years that he
sued in court not to acknowledge that
his his father callously cruy would not
acknowledge as president of the United
States which kid the only person in
public life who has attacked Hunter
Biden's wife and kids is Hunter Biden
himself and this this man this
degenerate has the audacity to accuse us
to accuse the Republicans of that
despicable I'm proud of my work on on
several Boards of directors yeah Boards
of directors like like the Ukraine oil
company that was paying you as graft to
to grease the wheels and enrich your
father because you were selling American
influence on his behalf you're proud of
your work as an unregistered foreign
agent pedling American influence for
your corrupt dad I wouldn't be proud of
that Public Public Service you know Joe
Biden that guy's made a lot of money for
public service usually public service
costs you money when George Washington
engaged in public service it made him
much less wealthy Thomas Jefferson died
in debt because of all of the time he
committed to Public Service Joe Biden's
a millionaire with multiple houses and a
Corvette and lots of nice stuff kind of
kind of weird boy what a great Sacrifice
from Joe Biden why is this happening
the reason this is happening now is that
Joe Biden might actually get impeached
this Hunter Biden story has been around
for years and Hunter Biden has
accidentally admitted on camera to
having conversations about his business
with his father he's accidentally
admitted in his uh laptop which became
public to giving his father paybacks in
fact we've seen the checks we've seen
the checks come in to Hunter and then
from Hunter to Joe's personal
account the reason this is happening now
is because Biden might actually get
impeached and that's not even the
problem because Biden's 300 years old
and he probably doesn't even want to be
president
again the reason that this is bad is if
he gets impeached if there's an actual
impeachment trial then the facts really
are going to come out it's not just
going to be in some closed door session
of the republicans in Congress it's
going to be before the American people
now speaking of
children there's a children babies came
up during that I think once right it's
not my best transition you got to check
out pre-born right now go to preborn
docomo Christmas season is upon us we
call it Advent then we're looking
forward to the end of the year when you
make all your donations and if you are
not sure what to give I will tell you
give the gift of life through this
Show's partnership with pre-born
pre-born is an organization that has
rescued over 270,000 babies from
abortion by offering
abortion-inducing
a mother's ultrasound pre-born also
supports mothers by providing them with
diapers car seats counseling and more
every day pre-born network of clinics
rescues 200 babies as they compete
head-to-head with the abortion Giants
now through a match your tax deductible
gift is doubled your donation offers
double the blessings now is the time to
put your yearend writeoffs to work have
your donation matched today by dialing
pound 250 and saying the keyword baby
that is pound 250 or donate securely at
pre-born KW that is pre-born dcoms pre
pror fundraises for its administrative
costs separately so every dollar you
give is going to go toward saving babies
give today preborn
docomo give the gift of a dailywire plus
annual membership for just 30% off go to
dailywire.com subscribe join today my
favorite comment last week is from
Alexander mindur who says Michael's
impression of fouchy is slowly becoming
alpacino with each performance now
listen here listen here you
she got a greater and you got your head
all the way up it now listen here it's
not it's not personal sunny it's just
business when I make you take that Vex
it's just business
son speaking
of drug addiction a very sad story came
out regarding Matthew Perry uh who died
in his hot tub some weeks ago well the
coroners report is back LA County
Medical Examiner says that he died of
the acute effect effects of ketamine
which led to cardiovascular
overstimulation and respiratory
depression now what's strange here is we
were told that Matthew Perry was clean
and sober at the time of death so now
people are going to conclude that that
was a lie but it it isn't exactly a lie
in that I bet Matthew Perry would have
said the same thing I bet I bet a lot of
people would say he was in at least a
certain clinical sense clean and sober
at the time of his death because
ketamine is used to treat drug addiction
it's used as a medical treatment
ketamine infusion therapy has been used
it to treat depression anxiety it's not
approved by the FDA for that use but it
is used to do that and it appears that
that's what Matthew Perry was doing he
had just recently had one of these
ketamine infusion therapy treatments th
those other contributing factors to his
death included drowning coronary artery
disease and Bo bootprint orine which is
an FDA approved drug for opioid
addiction but it's a drug in itself and
the reason that this story is so sad and
part of the reason the Matthew Perry uh
fell into it is is because of a
misconception in our in our culture now
that there are bad drugs that you're not
supposed to do and then there are
medicines which are really really
good but the line between hard drugs
narcotics and
medicines is a little bit
blurry drugs are drugs they can have all
sorts of bad effects on you whether the
FDA says they're good or not whether
your doctor says they're good or not I'm
not telling you never to take a drug
people take drugs all the time if I have
a little bit of a migraine I might take
an Advil but I'm not under the
impression that there are no side
effects from even a drug like Advil is
drugs you're putting a drug into your
system a chemical into your system and
that's going to have some kind of effect
now though people will say no no no I
was medically prescribed marijuana no I
was medically prescribed benzos no I was
medically prescribed opioids how how
many people develop opioid addictions
because they were initially prescribed
them by a doctor in supposedly totally
fine clinical circumstances isn't that
that's how Rush limbo became addicted to
opioids it's not that rush just went
down to a street corner one day and said
I want to get high Rush was prescribed
those drugs by a doctor and he like many
many people then became addicted to them
drugs are drugs and if we have not
learned the lesson over the last 3 years
to be perhaps somewhat skeptical of
people in white lab coats to recognize
that sometimes they seem to get things a
little bit wrong some of them seem to
get things a lot wrong then we haven't
learned a thing very very sad is people
you know I think it's what like one in
eight women in this country or more one
in five women regularly take depression
drugs
they're they're regularly on powerful
psychiatric drugs and we just ignore
that because we say oh was prescribed by
a doctor it's totally fine well I don't
know if it's great for a huge portion of
your population to constantly be on
powerful psychiatric drugs now on the
ever present topic of we're told that if
you give kids chemicals to stop their
puberty and to castrate them and to
induce all sorts of crazy bodily
consequences osteoporosis stero ility uh
potential early death we say no it's to
it's a medicine it's it's it's affirming
treatment for medical practitioners no
it's drugs it's really powerful drugs
maybe we ought to be a little cautious
about that because because things can go
south really quickly as sadly we we've
seen in this case now turning from Death
To Life a really great story a really
really great story to close on today
from the Charlotte lure Center uh report
this is is a survey that has shown that
pro-life pregnancy centers provided at
least $358 million in goods and services
to pregnant women last year that
includes half a million free ultrasounds
at least 200,000 tests for venial
disease 700,000 free pregnancy tests
400,000 parenting education programs
600,000 students who took sexual risk
avoidance education 4.3 million baby
outfits and by the way not just for the
babies and the mothers who chose to have
their children even for the women who
killed their children through abortion
19,000 people received postabortion
support at least probably the number is
much higher than that from pro-life
pregnancy
centers and this is a really good thing
because 32,000 more babies were born
last year than the year before thanks to
State abortion bans in the wake of the
dobs decision I I tell you I I kind of
like this legislating morality doesn't
it work I kind like the notion that
culture is Downstream of politics I kind
of like the idea that the law is a
teacher because it works it works and
saves 32,000 babies lives and then the
reason I bring up this story at all is
because you always hear the libs say
that conservatives only care about
babies in the womb you hear that one
they've been telling us that for decades
yeah you conservatives you care about
babies in the womb you just don't care
when they get out of the womb you mean
old conservatives uh I don't know
did is $358 million not enough that
seems like a lot in just private
donations that's that's
great for all sorts of women including
women who've had abortions it's pretty
good great way just a little that's a
nice little number tuck that number in
$358
million in private donations to women in
need
who are considering abortion who even
had abortion who uh chose to have their
baby heroically who need some help as as
mothers afterward that's a lot of money
and you ask those Libs you say oh yeah
did you what did you give you ever give
$350 million no you oh you've given
nothing to those women in need you've
given nothing to those babies in need
your our answer is to give at least $358
million to help them and and we'll give
more I'll happily give more give me tell
me the number I'm sure the pro-lifers
would give would give that and then
some any number to save to save babies
lives and the libs answer is nah we
don't want to give a single red scent we
just we just think you should kill your
baby
which is it which which which do you
think is more conducive to a flourishing
Society rest of the show continues now
you don't want to miss it become a
member use code n skw a check out for 2
months free on all annual
[Music]
plans